is today your birthday it is my birthday
yeah I just like to go on talk shows
celebrate my birthday it's a living baby
did you last year was a was a big burst
60 was last year this year 61 oh wow you
look great
thank you thank you you doin anything
tonight you doing any kind of
celebration no I'm going home and my
wife is arriving with my son they're
driving across the country in a van full
of his stuff and and my daughter happens
to be here in town so we're gonna have
some pizza I think and that's gonna
that's gonna be it just some pizza
that's it yeah I you know I'm not a big
birthday guy I'll be honest with you not
for me I like other people's burn either
of mine but I like to act like I am so I
don't really care but I try and just get
what I can out of it you know listen I'm
getting to be on your show but oh man
you're good he's good he's very good but
that'll be one of them
we have a clip here from city on a hill
what I love about this is that your
character is yes you're working on the
side of the law but you're kind of
somewhat compromised yes he's very easy
but he very rarely does a scene go by
when I am NOT doing something shady
inappropriate insensitive illegal I have
a lot of drugs I smoke I drink all the
time on the job I'm not landing I'm I'm
a I'm a bad guy yeah kind of an antihero
because you're trying to do the right
thing in some ways
[Music]
[Laughter]
dish made I think I think I'm here's the
thing I'm trying to do the right thing
according to my set of rules and what I
believe the right thing is but I don't
think most people watching would
consider anything that I do right well
if they do that's on you ya know in
Boston they're like I like this guy yeah
here's also like it is yeah we have a
clip here from city on a hill anything
we need to know here oh just talking to
a priest there you go
this is something we all do in Boston
let's take over this clip from City on
the hill
do you know that I was an altar boy was
yeah me can you imagine that I signed up
because of a priest Father Thomas looked
like Robert Mitchum a night of the
hunter something never killed anyone I
mean not after he took the vows he was a
World War two vet father Thomas he was
afraid of nothing I once saw him knock
out a piece of [ __ ] dad that was that
was beating his kid I love that guy
taught me about justice but then one day
a rumor starts but he's put in the word
to some of the working mothers in the
parish father Thomas he could take on
anyone but not after that not in that
neighborhood he was gone so much for
justice
the only hill city on a hill at Ricketts
show at airs Sundays at 9:00 on Showtime
and you should check it out and happy
birthday thanks button Kevin Bacon so
cool to see you again
[Applause]